today on the mat well show I have what I
hope will be a clarifying question that
deals with the ethical issues tied up in
the response to the China virus lots of
people think that the response is
overblown and and that is we're going
way overboard and it's going to do more
harm than good they might be right which
is why I hope that if you're in that
camp you listen to the show today and
think about how you would answer the
question that I'm gonna pose because I
think it's an important question also
five headlines including some expert
medical advice from the steamed scholar
and thinker Vanessa Hudgens and in your
daily cancellation well I'm not
cancelling anybody today but the the
Philadelphia Police Department has
essentially canceled itself and so we're
going to talk about that today as well
all of that's on the way on the Matt
Walsh show now so a question I'm gonna
ask a question it's a real question and
what I mean by that is it's it's not
something that's meant to be smarmy or
that I'm just asking rhetorically to
prove a point it's not a bad faith
question I really want to hear the
answer because I want to have this
conversation I don't know the answer
myself so when I say I'm asking a
question I mean that in the most direct
and literal sense of the phrase it's a
question and that is and I pose this
primarily to those who are on the this
is all a massive overreaction side of
the debate and it's this how many deaths
would be enough what what death toll
would you need to see before you would
agree that drastic economy damaging
possibly economy ruining measures should
be taken and whatever that number is if
you have a number or and if you like I
don't I don't think you would have an
exact for size number mine but whatever
that ballpark estimate is why why that
and not something else why do you draw
the line there and not somewhere else so
again this is a sincere question I
really want to hear answer and actually
the the question is more complicated
than that because if you say that you
would need the virus to kill say a
million Americans in order to justify
this kind of response if your position
is look I mean this response is going to
send
to a Great Depression this is something
that we never did this country is never
done before anything like this on this
scale to be doing something like this I
you know it would have to be like
something really cataclysmic and an
apocalyptic you know millions a million
two million Americans died okay well if
that's your answer
presumably you wouldn't wait for those
people to die before you respond this
the response would be to prevent those
deaths not in reaction to them so you
would need not for it to kill that money
but for it to threaten to kill that many
but then the problem is that some models
tell us that this virus would kill that
many if not more if we didn't do
anything and just treat it like the
common flu so how would you know you
know what would you need to see to know
that this other virus this hypothetical
virus really is threatening that many
considering you've decided or you know
you're theorizing that this that the one
we're dealing with actually is not
threatening that many so what would you
need to see this to me fundamentally is
is the philosophical kind of dilemma at
the heart of the whole debate
surrounding the China virus and our
reaction to it I've already said that
I'm gonna leave the analysis of the of
the the thing itself the disease itself
and predictions of what it might do or
how it might spread I'll leave that to
the experts but this question of where
we should draw the line for an
acceptable casualty count is not one
that I think doctors alone should be
trusted to answer you know we don't want
to get to the point where a question
like you know dealing with the value of
human life and life and death these
sorts of things we don't want to say
that oh only experts can speak on that
that that has very negative consequences
when you have that kind of mentality so
this is a human problem but I haven't
really heard or seen anybody try to
address it directly there there are many
people who seem to be rather confident
that we're taking measures that cannot
be justified considering the number of
people who are dying it's not enough
it's it's not enough death to justify it
the death toll isn't high enough I mean
this this is the argument that lots of
people
our making I just I haven't seen any of
them say what they think where they
think the line should be drawn so you
know we've all we've all heard arguments
like well the flu kills 60,000 people a
year in this country this has only
killed a hundred actually 100 1516 last
last last I saw or people will say yeah
the death toll in Italy was was bad but
it was only point zero zero whatever
percent of the total population or
they'll say hey you know just putting
this in perspective not saying that the
death toll isn't high for the China
virus but however many you know however
many people died from this here's how
many more people will die from car
accidents or something else every single
day all of these arguments are saying
rather explicitly that the virus death
toll is not high enough it's not where
it would need to be to make the reaction
defensible maybe it isn't so again how
high is high enough not a trick question
not a gotcha it's a question that I
think we absolutely have to be able to
answer because if you believe that X
cannot justify Y then you must have some
idea some at least general vague idea of
what would justify why because if you
don't if you have no idea then you can't
know that X doesn't justify it so this
just seems like a logical conclusion I
mean this is what I've been thinking
about because many of the people
claiming that this is an overreaction
it's they can make a compelling argument
especially when you think about how bad
this could get economically and all the
people that are going to lose their jobs
that might not get them back you know
what do we what does the economy look
like a month from now two months from
now how many people are out of work I
just read something saying I wish I had
it in front of me I think was something
like 20% of Americans already either
have lost their jobs or have had their
hours cut and it's only been a week
now I think that tells us something
about our system that a week of people
staying home just collapses everything
that's what we're talking about
yesterday that I think that what we
should be thinking about is a
fundamental restructuring of the way
we've set up society so that we're so
dependent on people being consumers that
they stopped being consumers for a week
everything goes to hell
but that's the way it is now right in
changing that's gonna take that's a long
term generational plan which I hope that
we will endeavor to do but it's not
something we can do every night
overnight so you point that out and you
say it's not just a fight it's too much
again that a compelling argument can be
made for that I admit but if you're
making that argument I think you have to
have some kind of response to the
question I'm asking we'll talk more
about this in a second but first I want
to tell you about our friends over at
Ben Cheryl watches you know tell you
about than Cheryl watches all the time
because I love them personally and we've
all been in the situation where you're
getting dressed you're going out
somewhere nice well not recently most of
us haven't had that experience but once
this is all past us again you'll be able
to get dressed up and go somewhere nice
but then you look down at your your
wrist and you realize that you're
missing something just your your empty
wrist is it's staring back at you
judgmentally because it's just this this
naked spot on your body that there could
be something there that classes
everything up no matter matter who you
are what you do for a job how old you
are or where you live there's always
gonna be an occasion where you want or
you need to look your best but before a
date and interview a wedding night out
whatever it is and a really nice classy
watch can do that for you even Cheryl
creates the most incredible looking
watches it's such an incredible price
point seriously watches that are
stunning and they're still under $200 so
they're a fly say I say they're
affordable they're not cheap because
cheap makes it sound like we've talked
about a cheap watch you think of
something that looks cheap this is not
than Cheryl Weiser very well made very
nice-looking watches but they're also
incredibly affordable as well the chair
has been a partner of the mat wall show
for some time now and I've never seen
them off for a deal that's good because
they just released a whole new lineup of
watches new styles for both men and
women and brand new unique colorways and
strap options of inch arrow is offering
for a limited time 20% off everything on
the website okay
everything none of their new items are
off limits 20% this is the best offer
they've ever had and let me tell you now
is the time to go take advantage of it
quick every second counts go to VI
see ero watches comm slash Walsh and use
my code walls for an exclusive
discounted checked out because you just
have to have one of these beautiful
timepieces and you got to take care of
that you got to take advantage of this
of this deal use my code Walsh I check
out for 20% off now so we're talking
about what you know if this is an
overreaction what would make it so that
it's not an overreaction and this is
focusing just on the death toll by the
way I think people who support the
measures that are being taken and the
want the people in government who are
enacting those measures would say that
it's not just about the death toll in
fact it's mainly about the strain on the
health care system and what they would
say is if we don't at least control the
spread of this that is that is in fact
the phrase they're using now less than
contain they're saying control the
spread if we don't control the spread
everybody gets sick at once we don't
have enough hospital beds we don't have
enough ventilators and that could
collapse the healthcare system but
putting that to the side which we really
can't do but but focusing just on the
death toll however that death toll would
come about because if you collapse the
health care system then there's going to
be even more people who die people who
don't even have coronaviruses are gonna
die as well but if we focus on that the
death toll we get back to the question
of how much is too much
say and there's an interesting point
about these comparisons that are made oh
it's like the flu or you're comparing it
to the car accident deaths or talking
about the overall percentage of people
versus the number of people who are
dying an interesting point people say
that it's no worse than the flu may even
be ultimately not as bad
well it seems from what the doctors are
saying that's actually not true but my
point is this what what if the virus is
only as bad as the flu or you know even
ultimately half as bad let's go with
what seems like a very conservative
estimate actually it's not even an
estimate because I'm pulling it out of
thin air it's just a hypothetical but
let's say that it's it's half as bad
let's say the flu kills 60,000 Americans
per year ruff ruff ruff Lee let's say
that this would kill 30,000 people
a year half as many as the flu now I
want to really dig into this apparent
assumption that the fact that 60,000
people are dying of one thing means that
we shouldn't take extraordinary measures
to protect the 30,000 who would die of
this other thing does that assumption
actually make sense what why have we
decided that the flu is sort of some
sort of litmus test or is the bar and as
long as it's under the flu deaths it's
you know it's it's it's it's it's not a
huge problem certainly not a problem
that would justify this kind of response
why is that I understand it this on a
visceral level I understand the argument
because we're so used to the flu but
does it actually make sense and what if
only a thousand people died of the flu
every year and 30,000 were going to die
of the corona virus well then we would
all agree that the latter is extremely
serious I mean probably probably we
would all agree that agree with that but
why why would the death toll of one
thing make the death toll of something
else better or worse what difference
does that make
I mean there's another way of looking at
these flu comparisons people say it's
just the flu the other side gets angry
at that statement I'm tempted to say
okay it is it is just the flu but the
flu is really damn serious it kills
60,000 people everyone's saying oh no
they kill 60,000 60,000 people's a lot
of people it's a really serious illness
so what maybe we should be putting the
word just or only in front of it now
isn't isn't that when we do that aren't
we sort of taking the flu we're taking
this the same approach to the flu that
people do to you know someone who's a
jerk at the office Bob at the office
who's a jerk to everybody and then you
make excuses for him and you say ods Bob
being Bob as if the fact that he's been
a jerk all along somehow makes his
jerkiness on any given occasion less
obnoxious and more acceptable well we
seem to be doing the same thing with the
flu as if the fact that the flu has been
killing people for a law
time suddenly makes it more acceptable
and less serious that's just the flu
being the flu is what the argument seems
to be saying so again I say what if what
if it is just the flu
isn't there an argument to be made that
we should all the more do whatever we
can within our power to stop it given
how utterly devastating we know the flu
to be what if we could go back in time
and stop the flu in its tracks what if
we could stop just the flu what if we
could go back many however however long
we would need to go back to stop the flu
wouldn't we do that even with extreme
measures wouldn't we do it considering
how many people it kills forget about in
a year but in a decade so that's a
question and I often wonder if we talk
about flu-like symptoms I wonder if the
phrase flu-like symptoms has become so
common and banal or banal as Alexander
Kaiser Cortez would say that we just we
can't help but not take it that
seriously so I wonder what if the China
virus had the exact same mortality rate
the exact same infection rate everything
was exactly the same but instead of it
being flu-like symptoms what if you what
if the main symptom was you let's say
bled out of your eyes
something scary like that and people who
die from it rather than dying of a
flu-like symptoms they die convulsing on
the ground do you think would we all
take it more seriously then my point is
what if everything was the same with
this virus except the symptoms were
weird and foreign and way scarier
sounding than respiratory illness I
wonder how that would change the
calculation or if it would maybe it
wouldn't or think about the percent the
the percent of population argument the
corona virus has only killed point zero
zero zero zero however many zeros
percent of the population right but
there are so far been like eight
thousand deaths
that's a vanishingly small percentage of
the overall population that's true but
what is death less tragic because there
are still a lot of people left over
isn't that looking at it that way isn't
that to commodify human life to say that
its value was somehow lessened by the
fact that there are so many other humans
still living on the planet so we
shouldn't be as concerned isn't that to
assume human life is a is a you know as
I said some sort of commodity
what if eight thousand people
represented twenty percent of the globe
would that make the deaths more tragic
would that give them more moral weight I
mean why does it matter how many people
are left over isn't that the wrong way
of looking at human life of course you
could argue that if twenty percent of
the population were to die that would
have a greater effect on the on the
lives of everybody else considering it's
such a huge percentage where as opposed
to a point zero zero zero whatever one
percent of people die and that's true
but that doesn't really answer the
question I still find it a little bit
troubling because that means that
arguably if a million people die of a
disease across the globe as long as
those deaths are spread out the right
way it's still not a huge deal because
it's still an extremely small percent of
the Earth's population and so we seem to
be saying that as the Earth's population
grows the value of human life is
lessened because there are so many of us
and now we can sort of tolerate or deal
with more people dying all at once of
some horrible illness now you could
throw this right back at me and and I
think if you're listening you're
probably screaming at this point at the
screen saying that there's another side
to this very argument that I'm making or
this question that I'm imposing and I
know that's true we're gonna get to that
in just a second but first I think this
is a very good time to tell you about
policy genius these are very troubling
times indeed it's a time when we're all
thinking about our mortality and now
there could be a better time to think
about policy genius and and policy
genius you know what they're going to do
is they're gonna make finding the right
life insurance a breeze and this is as I
said a really good time to think about
life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find your best price you could save 50
hundred dollars or more a year by using
policy genius to compare
life insurance policies once you apply
the policy genus team will handle all
the paperwork the red tape they're gonna
do all of that they're gonna make it
extremely easy for you to handle and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home auto or disability
insurance obviously dealing with the
death is very emotionally difficult the
grief that people experience but then
there's also the financial stress on top
of it which is very serious as well and
so we want to make sure that our loved
ones aren't going through that and
that's where policy genius can help so
if you don't know what's just around the
corner that's okay be prepared for
anything with life insurance in just a
few minutes you can find your best
enterprise and apply at policy genius
com that's policy genius.com again you
want to go there now policy genius will
always get the future wrong better get
life insurance right okay so these
questions I'm asking where do you draw
the line and everything there isn't
there's another side to it you could
throw it back at me from the other
direction and you could say okay well
how many deaths are too few if you think
the death toll and then threat to human
life right now from the virus justifies
all of these draconian measures then
where's the limit on the other side what
if only ten people had died so far and
from that pace of death it seemed like
only a few hundred would die across the
world would you then support all these
lockdowns and everything and and
shutting down the entire economy to stop
it what if only one person had died and
it looks like just a handful across the
world will die would you then say shut
everything down to save those people
and if I say to that no and that is my
answer of course no I wouldn't support
it then you could respond well isn't
every life infinitely valuable you know
I thought you just said that we can't
measure death tolls if as if lives our
commodities so where is the cutoff line
if one death is too few to justify the
measures and 8,000 is enough where was
the line crossed that would be a good
rebuttal and I don't really have an
answer to it that's why I'm asking the
question and trying to get people to
start thinking about it in these terms
because one thing I know for sure is
to criticize nothing wrong with
criticizing what we're doing now and the
steps that are being taken but to simply
just criticize it and say this is crazy
we shouldn't be doing it and to offer no
alternative or no better vision that's
just not very helpful and so I want to
start thinking along those lines here's
here's a maybe one way of framing the
question I think of the the six
principles of Just War Theory Just War
theory is a set of principles that are
supposed to help determine when it is
just and right and good to go to war to
wage war in a given circumstance there
are six principles which which should be
applied to determine the permissibility
of war itself and this could be relevant
to us because we are sort of I guess
waging a war on this virus and there is
in this case as there isn't any war
significant collateral damage that were
seeing right now it's only gonna get
worse so I was thinking about this last
night you you can kind of think of it in
those terms maybe so I go through items
four through six principles four through
six the six principles that are supposed
to just tell us whether a war is
justified principles four through six
number four reasonable prospect of
success meaning that you have a
particular goal in mind and there's a
sufficient probability that you'll
actually achieve that goal by taking
these steps and then number five is
proportionality which means the moral
good that you hope to achieve outweighs
the bad that might be done or caused in
the process of pursuing that that good
aim and then number six is necessity or
last resort so whatever the goal is and
and whatever good you want to achieve
you have to be sure that there isn't any
less extreme less violent way that would
be nearly as likely or just as likely or
more likely to achieve that aim because
if there is a less extreme strategy then
you should do that first war should be
the last resort
so we could see how this could apply to
fighting a war obviously an actual war
but I think it might also apply to this
antiviral war as well in some ways what
we're doing now is there a reasonable
chance that it will succeed how do we
even know what success will look like do
we know what success will look like is
this a proportional response in that the
good it might reasonably achieve
outweighs the bad that it might
reasonably cause and then is this
necessary or is there a less extreme
method that might achieve the same end I
think maybe if we run this all through
that filter system we get an answer
although I still don't know as I said
what the answer is that's the I suppose
the theme that we that we keep coming
back to is that I really don't know the
answer but these are all questions and I
would like to hear your answer to
everything I've posed so you can leave a
comment if you're watching on youtube or
send me an email but I'd like to hear it
now before we get to your five headlines
I want to tell you about a new book a
great new book called The Jerusalem
assassin by Joel C Rosenberg you know
Joel's an interesting guy he regularly
speaks with leaders around the world
about geopolitical and religious freedom
issues he's been called the most
powerful force in the evangelical
movement and I think he certainly is the
Jerusalem assassin delivers the
heart-pounding story of former US Secret
Service first Service agent Marcus Ryker
who works now for the CIA draws upon
real-life news event extensive research
you know that ripped from the headlines
feel which I really enjoy in a book
makes it feel relevant and urgent The
Jerusalem assassin uses fast-paced
edge-of-your-seat storytelling as a
springboard to provide insights and to
generate discussion so as is always the
case with great fiction it's not just a
story you know it's also something that
makes you think deeper about about
issues that are relevant to your life so
if you're looking for something to read
while you're locked down I think here it
is through the end of the month my
listeners can get the Jerusalem assassin
by Joel C Rosenberg for an additional
10% off at Tyndale comm it's tyn T y and
da
le comte ey and da le com by entering
Walsh at checkout alright let's go to
your five headlines number one reading
now from the AP it says in a massive
federal effort Tuesday President Donald
Trump asked Congress to speed emergency
checks to Americans and listed also
enlisted the military for mash like
hospitals and implored ordinary people
particularly socially active Millennials
to do their part by staying home to stop
the spread of the coronavirus his
proposed economic package alone could
approach a trillion dollars a rescue
initiative not seen seen since the Great
Recession Trump wants checks sent to the
public within two weeks and is urging
Congress to pass the stimulus package in
a matter of days so what they're talking
about doing right now is sending a
thousand dollar checks out to most
people I guess the question still is who
exactly gets the checks how do you
decide and if they take a means-testing
approach where they tried to be more
more directed and who they're sending
the checks to rather than just sending
them to everybody isn't that going to
slow down and complicate matters and
that's a problem because people need the
money now so I saw somebody propose one
solution which is send the checks to
basically everybody and then ask those
who don't need the checks to pass them
along to somebody else of course that
might sound massively naive because you
think well people get the money they're
gonna keep it for themselves but I think
a lot of Americans would be more than
happy it's a passed the buck as it were
to someone who needs it more than they
do I think that might that might be the
right way of doing this because you know
if you leave it up to communities and
individuals to find the needy or people
who actually could use it more than
others I think that's going to be more
efficient and is going to give you
access to those new year people rather
than asking the government to do it one
other point here I've heard people argue
that this this somehow proves that
Andrew yang was right all along because
Andrew yang was proposing the universal
basic income where everybody gets a
thousand dollars a month this is not
that at all
Andrew yang wanted to give people a
thousand dollars a month
perpetuity just as a system this would
be an extraordinary measure in a
national emergency presumably one time
or even if it happens more than once the
point is it's a it's a it's a limited
scope and scale in a national emergency
which is brought on by a pandemic so I
think it's a very different sort of
thing now I'm usually the last guy to
support handouts by the government but I
think in this case in this case I would
absolutely support it because people
need money it's really that simple what
other choice do we have and I think it's
also relevant to note that the reason
why so many people right now are not
working is because the government has
told them they're not allowed to and so
it's not any choice that they made I
think there are great many Americans who
if they had a choice in the matter
they'd still be going to work and taking
the risk if the government comes in
whether they're justified or not and
says you're not allowed to take that
risk you have to stay home and therefore
they lose a lot of money I think it's up
to the government to compensate them so
I don't consider this this is not you
know an entitlement or welfare or
socialism it's an entirely different
sort of thing number two there were
primaries last night Joe Biden swept
Arizona Florida Illinois for all intents
and purposes this now makes in the
nominee not officially but but there's
really no path for Bernie Sanders but as
we as we learned yesterday we know that
Bernie Sanders probably would have won
all those states in a landslide if not
for the voter suppression I don't know
how the votes were suppressed but I'm
sure they were and if we talk to
Alexandre occasionally Cortes or one of
his other surrogates they'll probably be
happy to explain it number three I'm
going to give you just the headline here
from Rolling Stone it says porn industry
calls for shut down due to coronavirus
lots of people sent me this article and
said look it sounds like your plan is
working perfectly man and I have no
comment number four
fortunately noted scholar and medical
expert Vanessa Hudgens has finally
chimed in during this this trying time
people don't know what to do
Vanessa Hudgens is here actress in I
think what High School Musical and maybe
some other movies but I'm not sure she's
here to offer guidance and reassurance
to a world in crisis
listen yeah till July it sounds like a
bunch of bull I'm sorry but like it's a
virus I get it like I respect it but at
the same time like even if everybody
gets it like yeah people are gonna die
it's just terrible but like inevitable I
don't know yeah like I mean like like
this virus so like it's just weird you
know like the virus is so like it's just
like it's like this like thing that like
is just so weird yeah people are gonna
die all I want to do here is remind you
I don't even I'm not even gonna respond
to what she said because who cares but I
want to remind you that the person you
just listened to there was born in 1988
two years after me that makes her 31 she
is 31 years old and talking like that I
don't even care what about what she's
what she actually said the substance of
what she said if we could even call her
substance is not the point I'm more
focused on
she's a 31 year old grown woman wealthy
successful who speaks like that and I
hate to keep beating this drum but this
is exactly what I was talking about
yesterday about voting do you think she
could pass a middle school civics exam
or English exam
what would the country be a better or
worse place if she was not allowed to
vote that's the question
number five an aquarium in Chicago has
shut down because of the China virus
this week they decided to let their
Penguins because I figured I guess
nobody's here so might as well let the
Penguins roam free and check out the
other exhibits and they put that video
online and it went viral as you could
expect because all penguin and kitten
related videos do selfish penguin
bastards just enjoying their time while
the rest of us deal with Armageddon
that's all they care about
enormous ly selfish creatures are
penguins people don't realize that
you know there I think they're they're
massively overrated actually on second
thought do we Eve everyone assumes
they're enjoying themselves but do we
how do we know that they are I mean
aren't they probably just now realizing
that they live in an exhibit along with
hundreds of other enslaved and
imprisoned creatures so isn't this isn't
this for them kind of like their Truman
Show moment remember remember at the end
of Truman Show Jim Carrey learns that
he's part of a reality TV show but in
that case he got to leave and it was the
heroic inspirational moment where he
finally left and chose freedom but for
these Penguins their whole world is
turned upside down they learned that
everything that they had previously
believed was a lie
that they're nothing but circus freaks
in an exhibit and they have to go right
back into the cage they don't get
freedom and you think you're doing them
a favor and look at this everyone sees
the expression on their faces and thinks
that that's a confession of joy but I
think it might be an expression of
mental anguish horrifying all right
let's move on to your daily cancellation
in fact as I said this is not me
canceling anybody this is a self-imposed
cancellation that I think will lead to
horrible consequences and we'll talk
about that in just a second but you know
I hope you've had a chance to see some
of the some of the new show we launched
this week it's called all-access live
over at Daley wire.com ben shapiro and
jeremy boring kicked off Monday evening
and then he and Michael Knowles followed
up last night we're gonna be doing an
episode the rest of this week every
night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern and the deal
is if you haven't seen it all access
live is is kind of unique programming at
the deli wire because usually our
podcasts are highly produced on stunning
beautiful stat sets like the one you see
here just that a lot of work went into
this and that bookshelf behind me you
have no idea in fact that's a those are
that's camera tricks that's CGI so nice
it is also because I don't really read
books those are all fake but that's
because the focus you know with with
this show is gonna be a lot more casual
a lot more relaxed the focus isn't on
production as it is on connecting with
you guys the audience this show is
actually intended for our all-access
members but in order to help us all feel
a little bit less lonely during this
time we have accelerated the launch and
open it up to all of our daily wire
members for the time being so please let
us know if you like the show and what
would you look what we what you would
like to see more or less of with the
show and in general we're gonna help you
get through this and we're all going to
be stronger as a nation and as a
community when we do so if you're around
at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific
tonight you can join us at all access
for the all-access live show over at
daily wire calm to watch the live stream
and also join the chat because as I said
this is a very interactive sort of thing
that's the whole point you can take part
in the discussion it's not just a
one-sided or we're pontificating in your
face okay now did the daily cancellation
the Philadelphia Police Department has
canceled itself reading now from the Fox
29 website they're the local affiliate
there in the city it says in response to
the Cova 19 outbreak Philadelphia police
officers have been instructed to stop
making arrests for certain nonviolent
crimes the department said individuals
who would normally be arrested in
processed at a detect at a detective
division will be temporarily detained to
confirm identification and complete
necessary paperwork the individual will
then be arrested on a warrant at a later
date
which means in between they're gonna be
released back into the public Fox 29's
Steve Keely reports the non violent
crimes include the following all
narcotics offenses theft from persons
retail theft theft from auto burglary
vandalism bench warrants stolen auto
economic crimes and prostitution that's
ten categories right there I just
counted Fraternal Order of Police Lodge
number five President John Nesby says we
are supportive of Commissioner outlaws
commissioner outlaw is that really his
name okay we'll just go with it
of commissioner outlaws directive on
making arrests during the coronavirus
crisis the directive was released to
keep officers safe during the public
health crisis meanwhile violent
offenders will be arrested in processed
with the guidance of a police supervisor
okay so we have two issues here number
one they've decided not to prosecute
these crimes for the time being number
two they announced it to the public
which even if the first can be justified
which I think it almost certainly cannot
be I mean I would love to hear the
argument for it but even if you could
why do you need to tell people this this
is nothing less than a written
invitation telling you to go rob from
from from people I and I would say you
know I'll defer maybe to any police
officers watching and understands more
what these crimes and tell but theft
from a person seems like that could be a
violent crime or it could get very close
to violence now stolen auto I mean yeah
okay there might not be violence
involved so I assume that doesn't
include a carjacking but even so these
are actually serious crimes theft is a
serious crime it's not it's not like
they're saying for the time being we're
not gonna arrest 16 year olds for
smoking weed
these are serious crimes that they have
announced they're not going to arrest
you for and on top of that this is
during a time when the economy is taking
a massive hit people are losing their
jobs people are gonna start getting
desperate and if you live in that city
you've just been told that you're not
gonna be arrested at least for the time
being if you go and steal from somebody
hey this is a this is just pulling a pin
from the grenade and tossing it into a
crowd that's what this is that's
unbelievable we'll talk more about that
maybe tomorrow let's go to emails this
first is from Dan says hello sir I
really enjoyed your show today I wanted
to share my opinion with you I work as a
psychiatric nurse practitioner this is a
very similar job to that of a
psychiatrist my job is to diagnose and
treat mental health conditions including
attention deficit hyperactive
disorder I don't work with kids and I'm
not really comfortable doing so but it
struck me that your opinion about
treating somebody someone into something
that that they should be rather than
what they are was very oppression I've
never considered this as a philosophical
question but I think you're a little bit
mistaken here you seem to be talking
about children that have more benign
conditions or lesser forms of ADHD and
other mental health disorders what most
people don't see and what I think you
have little experience in is the severe
forms of these disorders that can't of
that sometimes require hospitalization
there really are kids out there that
can't stop hurting themselves without
intervention that really are children
out there who have command
hallucinations that make them want to
kill their parents if they stop taking
anti psychotic meds that really are kids
out there who simply cannot sit still
and function in this world without
stimulant medication we can have a
discussion about whether medications are
appropriate for these kids but when
things get really difficult that
discussion needs to be put on hold and
treatment needs to begin immediately
just something to consider when talking
about these disorders well Dan I
certainly never said that there is never
a circumstance where a child should be
on anti-psychotic medication that's not
my view I didn't say that it's
impossible for a child to get a mental
health disorder or mental illness when
you're talking about hallucinations
you're talking about a kid who wants to
kill his parents that sort of thing that
to me is clearly a mental health
condition but that's not ADHD and if you
tell me that in extreme cases that can
be part of ADHD well I would say again
but we probably shouldn't be calling
that ADHD in that case that sounds like
something completely different
there's just no question that the vast
majority of kids who are diagnosed with
ADHD are not killing their parents or
threatening to and are not having
hallucinations
they just can't sit still and you
included you included that you said
there are kids that really can't sit
still well but you included that along
in lumped it in with seemingly things
like hallucinations and violent wanting
to kill the parents necessary I just I
don't think it's below its I don't think
it's anywhere in the same ballpark a kid
who really can't sit still that's my
point especially with young boys
I actually do have experience with this
the first two things you mentioned
you're right I have no experience there
but with with a with a young boy who
really cannot sit still I have
experience with that that's my son
he's six years old that's him that's
also me by the way even now I might that
was me when I was a kid that's even me
now in a lot of ways but yeah I'm
dealing with that right now with my son
but to me he seems very much like most
of his friends it doesn't seem that at
yeah it's it's difficult it's
challenging it could be very hard to get
him to focus on things it could be
overwhelming at times I like that he has
so much energy but there are times when
you want to say okay kid just please
calm down please please right that that
have I had that feeling a lot in fact so
I understand I understand the challenges
but I still say it's pretty normal and
even if it's not Who am I to say that my
son isn't supposed to be like that what
is really the problem with it other than
it's annoying to me and it makes it
difficult for him to sit in a classroom
for eight hours a day well the fact that
it's a note that it can be annoying to
the parents is kind of irrelevant
you just have to deal with it as a
parent and the fact that it makes it
difficult for him to sit in a classroom
for eight hours a day
well that might mean that he shouldn't
be in a classroom for eight hours a day
that might mean that that form of
Education isn't for him and so you have
to make and that's why we don't it's one
of the reasons why we don't have our
kids in the public school system so I
think you have to make a decision about
you know art are you going to try to
force your kid to conform with that
system or are you going to try to
educate him in a way that conforms more
to his needs and to who he is I think
the latter approach is better I
understand that not everyone can do it
but I do think it's better and I just
don't think there could ever be a
scenario where it's okay to give someone
an antipsychotic medicine just so they
can pay attention in school if they're
having hallucinations all these things
then yeah but if that's the only issue I
don't care how it
dream it is I don't think it's the right
move
let's go finally quickly to Steve who
says Matt I was really disappointed in
your show yesterday you seemed not to
care about the financial hardship so
many are going through stay and stay in
quarantine forever in quotes really yeah
it might be easy for you because you
haven't felt the effect but we can't all
become farmers overnight it seems like
you're completely dismissing and
unconcerned about what people are going
through it's all good it's all good to
you and your comfortable life that's
what I took away from your show that's
what you took away from it Steve did you
listen to what I was saying or did you
just base that on the title of the
episode obviously I don't think we
should literally stay in quarantine
forever yes that was the title the
episode is it's just a snappy little
title supposed to encourage you to
listen very often I use titles that are
not entirely literal that's kind of
common for headlines and titles
especially for things that are opinion
based the idea is listen to what I have
to say now if you don't want to listen
that's perfectly fine but then why why
are you reacting to the title just
ignore the title in that case if you did
actually listen then you would know that
I fully understand and appreciate the
financial hardship I I'm not gonna go
into details about it but my family
actually has felt it already we have
lost our looking to lose a significant
amount of money in fact already from
this and now I don't have it nearly as
bad as a lot of other people do so
that's that's not my point okay and if I
get that check from the government I
will pass it along because we we don't
we don't have it as bad as that or
anywhere anywhere close to it but you
know I've got this I got four kids and a
wife and I'm the primary breadwinner in
the family and so yeah I am feeling it
I'm feeling it in a not insignificant
way right so you're wrong about that
that's an assumption you made that
you're wrong about my point yesterday
and and in general I'm very sympathetic
to the economic hardship angle of it and
I'm very worried about how bad this
could get the idea of us going through a
Great Depression of course I'm worried
about that who wouldn't be I'm not I'm
not psychotic and let me tell you
something if we go through something
that bad
it's gonna touch almost everybody unless
you're extremely wealthy which I am not
my point yesterday and I said this
explicitly and I don't know what else I
can do but make my point explicit and
just tell you what I'm saying
if you refuse to listen to that there's
nothing else I can do I can't force you
to listen to it so I said explicitly
especially that I think this crisis has
helped to reveal some serious structural
flaws in the way that we have set up
society and our economy I think it would
be a good move to slowly gradually over
a long period of time move us towards a
society where people are more
self-sufficient and less dependent and
more family oriented a society in the
future where it would not be cataclysmic
if people have to stay in their homes
for a week or two
now I said multiple times this would
have to be a gradual change you can't do
it overnight if you do it overnight like
chaplet is happening right now
very bad things happen and I don't like
that these bad things are happening I'm
worried about them so when I say stay
quarantined forever what I mean is as I
explained very clearly that we should
try to move gradually to a place as a
society where many of the kinds of
things that we do in quarantine like
spend more time with our family cook
meals at home homeschool the kids are
more normal and common parts of everyday
life and my claim is that if we do that
and we have a society like that people
are going to be happier more fulfilled
it's a better way to live and we're
gonna be far more prepared for things
like this because our economy and
society is not nearly as dependent on
people being dependent and therefore
needing to buy everything you know
needing to fill all of their necessities
in the marketplace by buying things
because they can fend for themselves a
little bit more that's my point
but this dream scenario that I'm
painting this is generations down the
line if we even moved in that direction
as a society it's not something I would
see come to fruition
probably my kids wouldn't see it either
we're talking about many years down the
line what I'm saying is maybe we should
start moving there in the meantime
though in the short term there's a very
serious economic problem here and
that's why I just said I I think to
begin with the idea of a stimulus checks
not to corporations but to individual
people who are suffering is a good idea
and then we need to start thinking about
other things that can be done as well
and I do think that ultimately you know
there are some things the government can
do and should do but ultimately this is
going to be an issue of communities
helping each other and we have to be
willing to do that if we're not going to
do that then there's been it's it's it's
there's really no limit to how bad it
can get
but I think we will you know that's a I
could be cynical but I still believe as
Americans we do we do have a sense of
community and when a Cohen push comes to
shove we tend to band together I think
at least on maybe not on Twitter but and
maybe not in Washington but in
communities anyway so I hope that
happens here all right we'll leave that
at that and I hope you guys have a great
day stay safe Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 as the u.s. death toll from the Wu
flu hits 100 some experts are wondering
whether grinding the global economy to a
halt might have been something of an
overreaction we examine the scientific
data and the philosophical reasons why
the left never lets a crisis go to waste
then President Trump officially secures
the Republican nomination for president
and Joe Biden is set to sail to his own
party's nomination if he can only
remember who and where he is all that
more check it out on a Michael Knowles
show
[Music]